hello dr. Wallach okay my sister
Charlene just came from the cardiologist
we're sitting in a car pulled over and
it'll miracle we got through to you okay
so she's it's her birthday today she's
57 years old she's 240 pounds five six
seven she has a right coronary artery
that he believes was born she was born
with a defect so when she was shoveling
snow because the symptoms she told him
when she went to get one of her
medications refilled they because of
what she said it's hard to shovel snow
and it's hard to breathe out of breath
they put her on the treadmill and she
went to 270 her high blood pressure so
now they want to do
open-heart surgery and rewrote aiko
artery from her leg and so she's on four
medications they wanted to artery bypass
surgery she's on photo op they're
permitted out there for a minute
now before this shoveling snow event
where she got breathless was young heart
medication blood pressure medication and
I'm also aspirin
uh-huh okay has she had any stroke or
heart attacks or chest pains or anything
like that
the cordis event she's had chest pain on
and off like when she exerts herself if
she walks too far carries in doing so
far I would be I would be amazed if it
was a birth defect because this would
have been noticed when the baby was born
not when she's 57 years old okay
they didn't do a cat scan and they did
do another test a dye test on earth he
said today the cardiologist said because
of your symptoms we're going to do that
attention because of what I learned what
was the result
what was the results of the digest the
dye test showed a blockage of a pinching
not blockage they said that zero black
for calcium buildup zero where such a
specific
was a blast they thought it was a
blockage so they actually just went
ahead and started trying to put the
stint up there but they couldn't get the
spins up there so they took the steps
back down error and then they said let's
do this let's keep her in overnight and
let's do the cat scan then the next day
okay I'm still not with you did they
find that she has a compression or a
pinching of one of those arteries
pinching that's the word pinching but
they rewrote it he also said it's kind
of like a little detour the right yeah
it goes between two arteries and they
believe that well here's what happens
your your heart once they have blood to
itself and when there's arteries that
aren't doing their job and may be
partially blocked or pinched they'll
actually grow other arteries and reroute
themselves and so forth given time and
so that's not unusual for that sort of
thing to happen 240 pounds she's a
little heavy here and one you know five
foot seven for lady I'd like to see her
weigh like 150 160 so she needs was
about I'd say 90 pounds maybe we need to
have her lose 90 pounds and we can
actually help her support healthy blood
pressure we can support healthy blood
flow three even arteries or 95% blockage
did they give you a percentage of how
much blockage it was because of pinching
no only when she exerts herself does it
start to pinch span yeah okay so I
didn't give a percentage of blocking or
anything like that
okay that's 240 pounds I would give your
sister to healthier brain and heart
patcher month to healthy brain and heart
pastor month the full dose hurting twice
a day and because she has had wood
pressure and she has his artery problem
their heart but also give her two
bottles a month of the ultimate daily
classic tablets I never take three of
those ultimate daily cleansing catalysts
why sitting and they're going to support
remote healthy blood pressure they're
going to support promote healthy blood
flows from structured in pinched
arteries and for the weight in addition
to getting rid of all the bad foods
deprived to these processed meats oils
and gluten no we brother at oats
I also have or take
two files a month of the Rev re V and go
ahead and put two drivers full under her
tongue before each meal they've absorbed
through her old tissues one dropper full
ago on her tongue 30 minutes for the
meal and the second dropper full would
go 100 her tongue 15 is for its meal but
in seven to ten days she should start
losing a half a pound of two pounds a
day and it's not unusual to lose you
know 190 pounds 110 pounds that kind of
stuff
machine would require something like
four to six months do it comfortably and
of course as long as she stays on her 90
for life obviously she would she would
cut everything in half because you'd be
half the weight essentially right and
when she gets down to her proper way she
cut all her supplements in half and as
long as she stays in the 90 plaque
program the miracle here is she'll never
gain the weight back and so you know
give us call every two weeks we'll walk
you through this we just need to know
her blood pressure levels for her body
weight so we'll kind of understand you
know how well she's stickin to the diet
and taking the Rev and the other
supplements and every time she goes into
the doctor you know he's gonna examine
her EKGs can scans all the con stuff
we'll know what's going on with those
arteries and so let us know that but
calls in two weeks let us know again
weight and blood pressure and how she
feels and so on